これじゃあ肇社長です私の湯には様々なお客さんが今までたくさん来てるんですけども
今回はマジですごい方たちが来ておりますどうぞ
アーサー
ああああああ
うぇい配当だけでジャニーズジュニア美少年の皆さんねー
[拍手]
すけかおいていいですかはいっ
ブーバー紹介をよろしくねますはいえーとビション円の最年長の19 sg 納期です
よろしくお願いしまーす
ブーブー s ますよええ
ここにねせ日条例との予測体重前でお願いしまーす
どうぞ少年の悲しい性ですっごい人生で伝えしますはい
高校3年生特技はアクロバットです浮きすぎたかと申しますお願いします
バトルやです16歳ですここ2年生で好きな食べ物は目をしなさい
[拍手]
ブーバーカーポニー16期比安心ねは多分みんなと同じクロス
なりましょうまーす今日は何とお呼びしたらいい
何かいろんな呼び方されるんですよ札をっていう人もいたら
一さん今日も一目です初めていう人も結構いろいろいるんですけど
よ後輩から始めたって行くね
ねお願いしますし建設とみんなで選んでもらったいっぱい出しちゃった俺
風をどうぞ走れさ
僕らファンに殺されねー
部屋が鈴木を何かや初対面なんでお互いのことを知ろうみたいな
どんな感じかつ数えやっぱり
あいつを呼ぶきゃんっごい
恋あーんだけどビジョンへの皆さん youtube 仮にもアイドルというものが
存在していて空港にいる私始めちゃった沸かせるんですとここが youtube ない
どれなんですよどうですかイケメンでしょ
はいもう僕と立面は身も心も一アイドルなのでまぁ今日は皆さんそのアイドル的なこと
を学びたいと思いつっても我々も負けてないと思うんで
ホワイトこと済みしてありますで何個か質問とか書いてもらうの考えてきてるんで言っ
たお題に対してアイドルっぽく書いていただければいいじゃああああ
わかりましたずっと挨拶というかあさいまたセメント僕もこのアイドルなんでー
書いても皆さんと同じような答えが書かれると思ったよ
皆さん書いてもらってランダムにしてはじめが書いているのがどれ買ってわかんないん
ですよ
ああ
の僕が出ますはい
あーあてないんだけどね皆さんの回答を見てアイドルというものをわかるし果て目が
支えたのがあふれか分からなかったらアイドルだしもう
テクニコが入れ替わって僕が書いてもアイドルパックでだったらわかんないと思うん
ですそしての僕もあり取れないじょぼああっもうみんな良いなぁみんな
そういうのをかきながらでビジョンでの皆様ことを擦りながら僕たち前だったこと学ん
でいるぞ
キャッシャー
あっっちょっと人数が多いので4人に聞いてみましょうかこの4人が今から答えてあげ
たの
ここように皆様にしましょうパンデフせて俺たちでどれがたて微熱か当てる
はい1問名好き内容は何ですかおおーー
我々に悩みましたです eye drops 号がやってアイドルっぽくコレアイドル
生徒はれますよねっ
なーんあけましたかさあいきましたあーちょっとだけサックリしてくださいはい
[音楽]
ありがとうございますうぷろだとみましょう
はい本人はどれが誰のかわかんないんでから俺達4人で協力してどれがたためとか連れ
て行きましょうか
流行りが車小堤てきますそれぞれちょっと
[音楽]
ブーバーこれ
voodoo いきます4分
ピンクを見せてジッター
はるっ恋するネカマ4話に行きます
ドンッ陰茎を
[音楽]
ブービーのピンクピッピにあるべって r 触れもう
さらに美人ベッドって帰ったらポイントああああっ
よってよや服も正直インペリアルレッド
早いよあーーや周囲たことなないよねうんするだけでこの中で美少年が書いてない答え
は
んだ委員ペンやれる若いでしょはい
だろうぞ
いいよに変わりますかはいいえこの4人が答えて後ろ風人が誰が外れて植栽誰かを考え
てみてください
なんか先ほど聞いたんですけど美少年の皆さんキャッチコピーみたいなのが入っていい
ですよねーはい逆にマーチポピー温泉作るとしたらどんなつっに
みましょうはいうんむしろの形がかくれてください
[音楽]
よしずは書籍またサックリしますかはい
しています
ok はい
早速入りますか乗ってん2パーキラキライケメンアイドルドーン
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブーブー
逆ですね今んとこは彼らのところでもかわかんないですよはい
根ざすはでしょうねきらきらっとねくんでしょうね
no
最後にお願いしますはいいけめーサイボーグ
殲滅舞台卍効力起動特殊ありうるでしょうね
ウズ色々間違ったんだねいやー
はいどうぞ源さん
あのカードゲームとかやってらっしゃるんですね結構そういうのに出てきそうなワード
が
開く私はないかなという食べますねばようだがこれは本当にはからいつも思います
感じ的にわーわーへ
ロロああああ
ああああああああ
なんですけどねヨッシーのまっちゃんだけど a オレは好きですけど
次はですね趣味は何ですか
うわぁなるほどだけど皆さんの趣味じゃなくてアイドルっぽいんだルリカということ
なるほどちょっと間で試しされてるんだよ確かはい
前よりましたおしゃぶりください入っ
はいまあやりましょううんうんっ
アロマパワーのオシャレですね集め
満載パピ日ツアー
ついてはいいきますはいじゃあニコニコ生きる
ミカに濃いイベント小池唯みんなの見込み凝っていますね
アイスございますはいじゃんっ
伊藤
ああああああ
あればから乗ってわーいいならばちなみに打つのメンバーのかなさすがうあー
ブーバーし
4回目のいきましょうはい眼光で告白せるとしたらどこがいいですかおおおおー
ああああああ
相手の間生アイドル性シチュエーションですね応答と想像できるかなー皆さん隠れて
くださいはいい
4主さんくるしましょう探っはぁ
[音楽]
じゃあしぜひまだでまたそれから見てみましょう
せーのっ禅文化祭での発表会で
北
皆さん見てる前で打ってことをそうですねはい
全高集計で皆の前で好きな人へパー
相当気持ちはぜひそうなんでこれで良いか昔俺の中学校で行った人がいたんですけど
先生にめちゃくちゃ怒られたなぁ
あああああはい
音楽室に嬉しいな楽器でモールス信号
愛してるください某
はいど性はありますねあございまーです
本当によってカラー幸いですねはいこちらはい体育祭が終わったグラウンドのど真ん中
ああ
そうカム嬉しいなぁ見当つきますかなんとなく
だったんじゃないですよ
なんか
一つだけ特殊すぎるねお見せしますけどどれかはいえーノーダメ
僕ですねあっはぁ次ぎ競争 a 代表も目の前に以上が涙を流しながら倒れていました
あなたは何て声かけますか
うん
したら大丈夫で使っていくと思うんですけど速攻いかに
アイドルっぽく
撮影しますかございます
[音楽]
はいはいはい山いていきましょうはい
分入っと大丈夫涙じゃなくて僕と一緒に笑顔の涙長さっ
ダメ
[拍手]
あーこっちはこれじゃあ一緒に進む丸山さん婆さんあっていきますよはいダウンラクダ
強く生きろちょっととこでそこで
それで君の名は何発で頭から血が強かったと嬉しい関する経営なんて嘘吐い
ちゃんどうしたの君は涙より笑顔の方が100倍美しい4 a
言うでもねー最後いきますダンッ
どうしたら自分上がったが大好き
以上一緒に帰ろうか自分あなたの役影響
んですけどこんな会社まで来てますねはいじゃあああああ
これはだ二択な気がするぞ
そういやつはもうちょっと酸味はすごくアイドルっぽいなって思っちゃう
たらいいなぁどんだけの hots な気もするんですよ
そうねエースって言ってみます少しで一番って
まではたテミンの答えは生のこれ
世界とくれ4
まあこれ僕ですねこれはたりすぐココイチながらやわれ
ああ
良いお願いしますか暗いぞラストの質問です皆さん曲とかよく歌われると思うんです
けども
もし自分が服を作るとしたらローいう題名にします
もう
re ばーわーラブドールです
なるほどなるほど visions 2 d 題名の曲とかありますか
ラブソングっぽいそんなんじゃねぇもっと
うわぁ
ああいうのですね
[音楽]
電話車花咲くしますかはいはい
ファンサークルできましたはい楽しめて皆さん
今この星のどこかにいる君へ
8よああ
あー落ち着いたパターントッポ意気だぞなんだか雪なって何かいいなぁ
で次は妻
oes 1通算
ぼばナイスでえっとこれをあのツッコミづらい荒川村いる
これ夏っぽいねあがー軽い感じだっ
そして夏っぽいバカス w
まんまたべ
はいしているブルーああああ
ないしてるそれも説明ですねそうだもう
ずにっていうのはねぇ
なところに持った
なるほど麻生ございますはい
はいチームの肋骨に露骨にロックオンツアーおっあるああああこれカーロスもう1にょ
殺さああこれが多くよく食べちゃおう
物って感じ月に6じゃないですよね
はっはっはっキー僕じゃないった時に入るぞあったんですよああ
rar
ああああああ
の.ん
てくれっ
[音楽]
me
うううう
car
ああっあった